[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
uh wherever you might be joining us from
today uh my name is elisa koppel i'm a
member of the mba admissions team here
at the stanford gsb i want to thank all
of you for joining us today for this
session called your journey now i know
from women leaders um we are going to um
have a wonderful panel but first i
wanted to talk a little bit about our
global community and specifically
the community of women that both come to
the gsb and are now
out in the world as alums of the program
um i will ask some questions to our
panelists so that they can
start sharing their experiences and
start sharing their insights about their
time at the stanford gsb but this
session is also for you
so not only do we want to hear who you
are and where you're calling in from in
the q a pod but feel free throughout
this session to ask questions in that
too
um for all of you joining today you'll
have the chance to upvote a question so
if someone asks something that you also
want to hear the answer to don't feel
free don't feel the need to ask the
question again you can just vote a
thumbs up and it'll help raise that
question to the top and we'll try to get
to as many as we can today
um so with that
uh the gsb alumni is you'll hear the
term you're joining the gsb family when
you come to the stanford family when you
come to the gsb um that holds very true
and hopefully you'll hear perspectives
about that from our panelists today but
um the
alumni community is 30 000 plus strong
um there are 60 volunteer-led regional
chapters that are around the world so
even just getting a sense of where
you're calling in from today is really a
great representation um of just the
global nature of the program
specific to women there are women's
programs that there's obviously a club
on campus that supports women through
their journey during their time at the
gsb but also upon graduation there are
numerous resources for women and one of
the
more well-known programs that you might
hear about is something called women's
circles i'm not sure if any of our
panelists are involved in those but if
so um we'd love to hear about your
experience in that
and then there's also as alums of the
program support from our career services
and other learning programs available to
you as you continue to grow
throughout your career post gsb
so today we have our panelists joining
us um
i'd like to have them introduce
themselves so i have information on each
of them up here but i will actually ask
each of them to
specifically introduce themselves and
then
as they introduce themselves you can
share kind of what you were doing before
the gsb and where you are now but i'd
also love for each of you to share what
was your most memorable experience
during your time at the gsb so this
could be a class that you took it could
be a trip that you took um you know
anything that kind of comes to mind when
i say what uh really impacted you during
your time at the gc what's your top
memory um so with that
um anik would you be willing to start
sure hi um my name is annika uh i'm
sorry
that's all right um i graduated from
from the gsb in 2012. um so you wanted a
sort of a short intro and then yeah
intro and then if you can share what was
kind of most impactful or memorable for
you that would be great yeah of course i
i came to the gsb from consulting had
done some entrepreneurship on the side
um since the gsb have mostly been at
tech startups i did a small stint at
google but otherwise have been at sort
of seed stage through series b series c
startups i've been the ceo at the last
few and currently now i am at stripe
working on new products for startups
where i you know was the i used to be
the customer for this kind of product um
and oh gosh uh probably one of the
things that's most memorable to me from
the gsb was actually in my whim group my
women in management group um and i think
it just reinforced one of the biggest
takeaways that i had which was the
opportunities to really go deep with and
engage with people who you wouldn't
necessarily have like picked to have
been friends with like in the places
where you're sort of forced together
with folks uh wim group is a great
example some of the trips that you go on
classes etc um are just really beautiful
opportunities to build relationships
that you know may not have waltzed into
your life under other circumstances and
i really treasure some of those
relationships today
awesome thanks for sharing i'm tamer why
don't you go next to you
hi everyone i'm tamer um i'm so excited
to be here i like absolutely loved my
gsb experience so definitely pumped to
talk to you all about it um especially
uh like the perspective as a woman so my
background was in technology and media
before school i worked at youtube in the
bay area i was on the content strategy
team there my team was responsible for
writing the help center we worked with
creators on their monetization
um like strategies and so i did mostly
partnerships now i'm at netflix i'm also
on the content strategy team but it's
vastly different it's much more like a
finance and strategic role um and we
focus on what are the valuations for the
shows that we're putting on what um is
the competitive intelligence what's
going on like in the world around us um
as well as just like what types of shows
we should renew and cancel and what we
should be making i work on reality tv
which i watched all the time anyway
before i got to netflix so if you have
questions about bling empire selling
sunset nailed it that's what i work on
um
and i have so many great memories from
the gsb but i think probably my my
favorites were all the travel that i got
to do um i was really choosing between
stanford and another program where i
would have been able to do a dual
master's degree and like learn um more
french and like spend a lot of time in
africa and so i made it a goal of mine
to go to africa as much as possible
while i was at the gsb i was able to
visit i think nine african countries in
the two years that i was here which is
insane um and my favorite was
probably uh my
g mix which was in togo i worked for the
government of togo in west africa i
spoke french there and i worked on their
incubator strategy for
uh startups in the region especially
thinking about agritech and like how
they can make a better incubator and so
that was just insane and not an
opportunity i would have had had i not
gone to the gsb to like literally work
um at the top like government agency
working on startups in west africa so
that was my favorite among many other uh
trips to africa that i went on fgsb
awesome thank you for sharing that um
sethara why don't we go to you next
sure hi everyone um i'm sithara i was
the class of 2018 at the gsb
uh before the gsb i had a had a kind of
strange career i started in investment
banking i worked in public finance at
jpmorgan and then
took a 80 pay cut to be an americorps
volunteer at a non-profit
loved it um basically worked with impact
investors to
scale up
social services and local communities so
did that for a few years before the gsb
and then came into the gsb kind of
uh sort of undecided on what i wanted to
do explored a couple different
industries my first year there
ended up really liking um a lot of kind
of the social impact focus of health
care but feeling like i had flexibility
to build a career both in the private
and the public sector
so post gsb
um i now work at bright health which is
um a company that's about five years uh
five years old um has grown really
rapidly and kind of offers health plans
on the aca exchanges
and oh gosh um my most memorable
experience at the gsb i feel like it's
it's hard to pick i think
one experience that really stands out to
me was um
a few friends and i led a global study
trip our second year which is something
second year students do
um and all of us had grown up in the
midwest so we decided to lead a global
study trip uh that was basically five
minivans driving through the midwest we
started in pittsburgh we ended up in
chicago we got to meet with um the ceo
of u.s steel as well as the head of
uber's self-driving car unit we
we met the head of um
we met dan gilbert who founded quicken
mortgage loans and now also owns the
cleveland cavaliers i had the joy of
trying to get him to stop talking an
hour and a half into our meeting
which i think is is the first and only
time i'll i'll have tried to get a
billionaire to shut up
and um
and we kind of ended our trip in chicago
we got to meet kind of pete but a judge
really got to introduce some of my some
of my classmates who were from so many
different countries so many parts of the
united states to a part of the country
that you know i i really love um and it
was just a really really thoughtful
wonderful trip with a really good group
of people
awesome thanks for sharing before we go
to heather next um and i see that arriba
joins thank you so much for joining it's
nice to see you um i do want to just uh
for those on the call you've heard a
couple acronyms thrown out gmix and then
you heard global study trip mentioned
which is for short called gst these are
different ways in which you can fulfill
another acronym which is your ger your
global experience requirement so a big
part of the stanford program is
encouraging you to
to go out of your comfort zone and one
of the ways in which that can be
encouraged is to require that you spend
time in a place that you have never
lived in or worked in before and that is
your global experience requirement it
can be fulfilled by doing a gst or doing
a g-mix so you've heard both of those
mentioned and then as you also heard
just now you can also lead a global
study trip in your second year so i just
want everyone on the call to understand
what's being talked about you'll hear
just an um large number of acronyms as
we start talking about the stanford gsb
so heather why don't we go next to
introduce yourself and share your most
impactful time and then ariba will go to
you next
hi everybody my name is heather i was
the class of 2020 with tamer
before
coming to stanford i worked as a
consultant at deloitte consulting in
chicago
um
and then
i came because i wasn't really sure what
i wanted to do next um
so i did something totally different for
my summer between my two years and i
went and worked at rothy's which makes
shoes out of recycled plastic water
bottles
i did product strategy for them and it
was a really awesome time but then
ultimately another hard pivot in my
second year i ended up taking a class
called startup garage which is
kind of a hands-on learning experience
and out of that class my my co-founder
and i actually did start the company
that we started as a part of that class
called frankly apparel and we make
braless clothing so perfect for your
pandemic wear needs um
so that's kind of that's what i've been
doing for the last year and a half um
i'm based in chicago we do almost
everything remotely but we produce in
los angeles and then
my most memorable experience at the gsb
kind of like everybody said it there's
so many like little moments and memories
with friends and the connections you
form
but i think i'll stay a little a little
closer to home one would be definitely
the the startup garage class because it
totally impacted what i did after i left
school um and one of our professors
actually ended up being an investor in
our company um so it really like made a
huge impact on on kind of where i went
with my future
and then the second would be my time as
an arbuckle fellow um that's a a
leadership program that you can do your
second year where you help guide first
year through a portion of their uh core
curriculum and you're really learning
like leadership and management skills um
really hands-on and as part of that you
get to take interpersonal dynamics or
touchy-feely a little bit earlier you
take it your first year
and taking that class our first year and
then having an entire year to practice
it with people that kind of spoke the
same language and were in the same
mindset
uh
changed so much about how i communicate
in all aspects of my life professional
personal everything so um those have had
a really lasting impact on who i am and
how i show up in in the world yeah
awesome thanks for sharing um and arriba
will have you go next um again sharing
introducing yourself and then sharing
what is your most impactful
memory or experience that you had at the
gsb
um you're representing our most recent
graduating class so um so it'll be great
to hear your perspective
uh thanks elisa um my name is ariba
and welcome to all of the folks joining
the skull um and to all of the alumni
here it's super exciting to be on the
panel with you
um i grew up in pakistan um have lived
in the states for about nine years
almost exactly actually yesterday was my
nine year anniversary of emigrating by
myself um
i celebrated it with a picnic in the
park in san francisco with a lot of my
gsb friends um and i worked in
consulting before the gsb and
i'm right now in a conference room at
apple park where i am the lead product
manager for all their accessibility
features across all their devices still
learning all the things that that
entails um and super excited about the
opportunity and and could not have
gotten here without the folks at the gsb
and i think my
my favorite memory of the gsb i'm going
to cheat and choose a theme rather than
a memory um but it has to do with
writing and speaking
um
i worked in finance and now work in
technology and if i had to just pick my
dream career it would have been a writer
or a journalist i'm the daughter of a
writer and
didn't always have the luxury of
thinking about humanities or arts just
because of visa constraints and
financial responsibilities it just
was much easier to work in consulting or
work in tech um but the gsb gave me gave
me a look at what it means to just
continue writing and speaking and and
living my life with words um
outside of
directly career paths and so i did
something called a low keynote which
which stands for
lives organizations and world the low in
there
um you can look up uh lowkey notes on
youtube there's a whole series of them
and every year somewhere around 20 gsb
students give a loki note on on a team
that they really care about and i got to
give a 10-minute talk on what it means
to integrate grief into your life i lost
a parent while i was at the gsb and
the experience of dealing with that um
and
of studying grief and its impacts on
like human psychology and um just just
your life and and what we get wrong
about it and what we get right about it
and putting that in the context of a
pandemic just being able to put an
academic structure around something as
personal as grief was was really
empowering for me and being able to give
a talk on that in the middle of it
pandemic that you know goes on the gsb
youtube was was incredibly
powerful also
i also encourage everyone here to look
at a non-disclosure
it's the gsb magazine you can find it on
medium and it's accessible to everyone
and i got to work with really awesome
folks and just writing pieces for for
the gsb magazine called non-disclosure
so for instance be advocated for
making all clubs at the gst completely
deuce-free and that was something that i
got to write with a classmate um i wrote
something on
just body image and eating disorders and
and what that means in terms of being a
professional woman and
navigating all sort of like body
politics and and the role of gender in
that and that was another thing that i
got to do for the gsb magazine
completely unrelated to any career paths
or well related to career but not
directly um yeah so non-disclosure
low-key notes two awesome things to
check out and two of my favorite
experiences um yeah they're just
opportunities every single day to speak
up in classes and um for those of you
who are not familiar with it already the
gsb talk is another amazing experience
that i got to partake in and and folks
typically do where every wednesday night
you spend an hour listening to two of
your classmates describe their journeys
through life and that spans all aspects
of your life not just your career and
the experience of giving a talk but also
listening to classmates describe their
lives and their backgrounds every
wednesday night um was was incredibly
empowering and so i think the gsb is a
place that encourages you to bring all
of yourself
into
your career and your social life and
your personal life and it really teaches
you how to communicate all the things
that are important to you and i i really
had a blast with that
awesome thank you so much for sharing
and those are all amazing things to
share with our audience today um as all
of you on this caller learning more
about the gsb um those are programs that
um as aruba said do encourage you to
bring your whole self and are also um a
lot of them are mentioned whether it's
arbuckle fellows or talk or low keynote
of just i'm pushing you to develop
yourself as a leader and understand you
know who you are and how you can
influence others um so those are all
just great examples thank you so much so
um one of our most highest upvoted
questions is what i'm gonna pose next to
all of you um and this is obviously
specific to the theme today of just
talking about being a woman in business
and a leader um how do you think
stanford specifically um and you know
this could be something again specific
to your time at stanford or even just
obtaining an mba from stanford how has
that prepared you as a leader
specifically a female leader um in your
career so
um i'm just going to start now at the
top of what look of my grid on zoom it's
so no specific order but heather you're
at the top of my grid so i'll start with
you on this one
sure perfect uh female founding team
female centric company i can definitely
talk to this to this theme
um
so a couple of things for me
uh the first is that there are a few
specific classes at
stanford that are particularly focused
on female leadership and or women in
leadership and actually both of them um
the two they're specifically women
leadership they also have diverse
leadership and other types of classes
that encompass women but there are two
that are specifically um focused on
women uh in leadership positions and uh
uh one with fern mandelbaum and one with
laura aryaga and driessen
they are
different quarters so you can take both
of them and they have slightly different
vents um and i actually found those
classes to be
great because of all the amazing female
speakers that came in um great because
of like the tactical tools and exercises
that you do
but also primarily because it's a lot of
really strong amazing women in the class
and this amazing female professor who
really cares about the women in her
class and often you will get a few men
and it's and i'm always so thrilled when
men join those classes just for the
record um i think they bring like a
really interesting perspective and shows
that they are interested in learning
about how fifty percent of the
population is impacted in their work um
i think it's really eye opening so and
that was one way um and then the other
one i think was really i came in coming
from a pretty male dominated field and
consulting
and i think i battled early in my career
before coming to gsb
a lot of this stereotypes associated
with being like an assertive woman in
the workplace especially a young um
assertive woman in the in the workplace
and i was really struggling kind of like
with my self-concept and how to stay
true to my personal leadership style
and be an authentic leader but still be
taken seriously um hamer can tell you
i'm a highly emotional person and i wear
my emotions on my sleeve
so i'm kind of trying to figure out how
to balance that in the workplace and
and all of these the opportunities that
i got to kind of put my leadership
skills to the test so through arbuckle
through interpersonal dynamics all of
these classes
helped me become a lot more confident in
how i was showing up and that my
specific brand of leadership had a place
in the workplace
awesome thanks for sharing annika um i
know you already shared with us in terms
of your most memorable experience being
your time with you know working with
women in management but um if you have
anything else to add we'd love to hear
that in terms of how it helped you in
your career
yeah for sure when folks ask me what you
know like did you actually learn
anything in your mba i always say that
particularly i think this is unique to
the stanford program my number one
learning and takeaway was that uh
authentically sharing vulnerability with
other people is the quickest way to
build
rapport and and sort of like the kind of
of intimacy that you need to do anything
that's like have a relationship build a
company lead a team like all of those
things come from the authentic sharing
of vulnerability which is like wait what
i feel like that is like not aligned
with what most people think an mba
program is about which is about you know
sort of like beating your chest and like
how can you be the next titan of
industry and that was not at all my
experience at stanford from everything
from the curriculum you know courses
that have already been
described here in detail but you know
talk i think is a great example whim
groups is a great example all of the
ways that you build connections with
with other people and find ways to
continue to show up more vulnerably in
an authentic way
really really helpful and that is
something that has allowed me i think to
lean into my own style of you know sort
of leadership as a woman of bringing
that kind of vulnerability uh to the way
that i engage with my team the way that
i am honest with my team in what i do
and don't know the way that i am honest
with my team when giving them feedback
the way that i'm honest with my team if
i'm at a startup and things are failing
what do i tell them like all of those
things require you being able to bring
that sort of vulnerability and sort of
confidence right you know i think when
you're not bringing vulnerability it's
sometimes about like putting up errors
and there's there's all kinds of
negative externalities that can come
from that which is i think aligned with
like a more traditionally kind of like
male way of approaching business and
decision making um and so you know while
it is not exclusively about you know
sort of like being a woman or not i
think that's something that's been
really helpful for me and something i've
heard from a lot of my female classmates
as well
awesome thanks
um tamer i have you next in my grid
yeah i love this question i definitely
agree with everything that's been said
um and heather i love that you're
emotional i think that something
that i learned from stanford is like
that there's power and difference no
matter
who you are or where you come from and
like to not show that part of yourself
is actually you're doing a disservice to
yourself and to your team and so
um i've always been like incredibly
bubbly but also i'm really happy to ask
tough questions and i realize in the
first few weeks at stanford like if
there was a professor or a guest that
said something that i disagreed with i
would immediately raise my hand and ask
a question or say this is why i disagree
it was a little bit scary at first but i
realized that um people saw that as like
authentic leadership and even if they
disagreed it was something that we could
have a conversation about afterward um
and it made me more confident to do that
not only in class but in going forward i
also think was a really important lesson
for me because
even though the team i'm on at netflix
is the same name as the team amazon at
youtube they're completely different
like i'm working on finance and strategy
which is something that i didn't
actually have experience in before my
internship at netflix like i was much
more on the content side i majored in
literature when i was at columbia like i
felt like i was a soft skilled person
and so to know that there was power in
my difference to know that if i showed
up i look different i speak different
like i came from google i'm going to
wear different things and people who are
on my team who mostly came from
consulting and banking like that's
actually a huge plus for me like people
are going to remember me because my name
is completely different it's hard to
pronounce i have to tell you again how
to pronounce it that means you remember
it yes annika i see you snapping and
then also like
just own that like show up as that
person um and so
i see there's a question about imposter
syndrome here too and i feel like that
goes into like being a woman and
learning how to lead through
feeling like
maybe i look different or i seem
different or like the way i talk is
different than everyone here but in fact
i found that it was my greatest strength
and the more that i leaned into it the
more that i remember what was said in my
classes and the better connections that
i made with people in and outside of my
classes so that's absolutely something
that i've brought with me to netflix
and something that definitely makes me
stand out at netflix as well and i think
that has made me
like a much better worker and if i had
tried or if i try to be
a version of me that i am actually not
i'm going to be unhappy and my work is
actually going to be worse than if i'm
just like the real version of myself
awesome thank you i'm so far i have you
next if you want to
answer that
yeah yeah i i love what everyone's been
saying so let me see if i can say
something that's that's a little
different since it's all such such a
good kind of good reflection on the
experience at stanford i think um i was
thinking about this and i was like how
like what am i as a female leader and
i think i immediately thought of a class
i took a spring spring quarter of my
second year called acting with power
um and the class is kind of
um taught kind of both with a professor
and with a woman who has more of an
acting background and in the thinking
and it's so strange to take an acting
class at the gsb and it's not like um
you know i especially had no talent and
like dreaded getting up in front of
class to like act out scenes but the
thinking is really like how can you like
experiment with like different behaviors
and and saying different things and
inhabiting different characters to kind
of figure out um what works for you
so
there's something about that i think
like post gsb that's like really
empowered me to feel like
listen like i if something is work isn't
working i can try something else and
that's okay like you know i've uh you
know i've been in situations uh
healthcare can be a really old school
industry and i've been in situations
where you know men just have like really
overpowering attitudes and
are kind of talking over each other in
meetings and and i feel like i can
experiment i can be like okay like i can
try to match that and and see you know
if i get a response and if i if i don't
get a response i can try something else
um
and and i feel like that was really
empowering to realize that i could adopt
this kind of curious mindset of
experimentation to figure out kind of
what resonated
um
i think the other part of it is honestly
getting to just
meet your classmates who are just so
incredible and talented and
honestly intimidating in so many ways
and i feel like i've had so many text
messages and and conversations with
friends post gsb about you know i've
been in this situation it made me feel a
little weird or like you know i'm facing
this challenge at work how how would you
handle it and these are friendships that
are like deeply personal friendships
right we go on vacation together we do
other things together but it's really
lovely to feel like you can also have
really deep meaningful conversations
about your career and leadership um in
addition to all of the other personal
things that you care about
awesome thank you
um ariba if there's anything else to add
feel free
uh i think we covered most spaces but i
will uh i'll plus one what
i just said about
having those people who you meet at the
gsb who who keep you honest friends who
keep you honest i think as i
approach my
my career and my role and
get used to working with
a lot of folks who don't who come from
very different backgrounds um it's it's
nice to still have those people in in
your life who know
all of you um
yeah like
just folks who you can talk to about you
know that are coming up that it's not
always appropriate to talk about at work
my what i'm thinking about is i will
spend a lot of time i'm working with
people who
don't necessarily look like me i work
with a lot of white male engineers every
day i talk to maybe
one woman for every four men
so it's really nice to have my
lovely you know group of mostly female
like gsb besties to text and talk to and
and just kind of describe you know how
i'm really feeling which like you don't
always have the luxury of doing that at
work and just having people who
know you at this deep visceral level and
who live within you know spitting
distance of you and in san francisco
like it's such a it's such a luxury and
it allows me to kind of compartmentalize
in other aspects of my career in life um
i think the other thing i was going to
say is
not necessarily
related to just being
female but the gsb did uh teach me that
people are people no matter what
industry or or role or geography they're
in i think as an immigrant i already
sort of knew this at
at some level um that my friends back
home and my friends here like they have
a lot in common and
you know
a lot you can build relationships and
and build strong connections with anyone
regardless of their background and i
think i'm more cognizant about um
approaching folks who are much more
senior than me or approaching folks with
very different skill sets or backgrounds
than me and and knowing that i can build
a connection with them and i can you
know have rapport with them and and
influence them and have them influence
me i think that was something that i
realized that the gsb with the help of
classes like
what what is proverbially called touchy
feely but it's officially called
interpersonal dynamics um there's a lot
of classes on interpersonal dynamics
beyond just touchy feely but i think
just being able to understand what
motivates someone what moves them how to
communicate with them how to build a
relationship with them regardless of
whether they look like me or not that
was really empowering to me because i
think before the gsb i always sought out
sponsors and mentors who were also women
or who were also people of color and i
i'm still going to keep doing that but
just by virtue of the space i work in
there aren't that many of those and i
kind of need you know every everyone in
my wheelhouse and so building the
confidence to build relationships with
with everyone around me i think i got a
lot of that at the gsb
awesome thank you
i'm gonna ask the next question and i'm
gonna just direct it to two of you but
by i'll meet just for sake of time so
that we can try to get through as many
questions as possible but if if some if
someone wants to say something by all
means speak up
so this one is actually i'm gonna start
with tamer because it's directed towards
a point that you made about just how you
chose the gsb um and the question is
what um was the final differentiator
that made you choose the gsb and i want
to make sure we just focus on like the
gsb because none of us then ended up
attending other universities so we can't
speak specifically to that but you know
just maybe what was your thought process
as you were making your decision and
that might help people considering the
gsb is a place to apply but also one day
um hopefully attend so us tamer and then
maybe sahara you can also and we'll have
both of you chime in on this
yeah definitely um it was a really
difficult decision for me because i
really wanted to um like be
international and i talked a little bit
about like the fact that i could have
done a dual degree at like the other
school that i was choosing but i think
what made me choose the gsb was that
honestly it scared me a little bit more
like there was this there was this focus
on interpersonal dynamics and like
getting deep with people
um i had lived in the bay for a long
time and had heard of venture capital
but like had no idea what that actually
meant and so i felt like the gsb would
push me out of my comfort zone in a way
that if i went to
any other school i might not have to be
pushed out of my comfort zone i could
like really easily retreat and so i
wanted to scare myself a little bit um
and so that's why i chose gsp
great thanks for sharing um so far i'm
curious to hear you know you can answer
the same question why the gsb
yeah it's actually it's interesting it's
like a little similar i went to um when
i was trying to decide i went to admit
weekend at the gsb and to be honest
i didn't love it you know i didn't i
didn't walk away being like oh my gosh
this place is amazing i'm in love with
it like i have to go here i walked away
and like maybe i'm too much of like a a
total midwesterner where like i don't
like talking about my feelings with
people i've just met i'm like why are
you asking me about this like we need to
chat about the weather for a couple
months before we can get there and like
i was just like you know like i feel
like there's so much like emphasis on
the like kind of
of course everyone at the gsp says like
the touchy-feely part of it and the kind
of like
intangibles and like
i feel like you know especially coming
from like a non-profit background like i
feel like i want to learn about business
right like i i like care about the
academics
and and then i thought about it and i
was like you know like
you literally wrote your gsb essay about
taking on uncomfortable experiences and
like and seeking those out so like isn't
it interesting that this makes you feel
uncomfortable and isn't that a sign that
there's you know a lot to learn here
so um
so that's actually kind of like what
ended up making the decision and i have
to say i i walked into day one of the
gsb being like i don't know if i'm gonna
like this but like i'll learn a lot and
like then i'll have it like on my resume
and that's fine and now i kind of laugh
at how i think about it because it ended
up being such a rewarding experience and
so much more than that
great thank you so much i'd love to just
add like a really really quick reason
for me
a lot of it to do with program size so i
came from an undergraduate experience it
was very small was all residential on
campus i loved that and the other
program the other mba program i was
looking at had maybe a thousand or more
students and the size of the the gsb
program was really attractive to me
because you have an opportunity to
really get to know all your classmates i
know literally all of my classmates and
that is really pays dividends and being
able to build relationships and having a
network that is really really strong and
then also you just have more of an
opportunity to meet professors meet
administrators there's just you know
like sort of fewer people up in the mix
and so you just have more opportunities
that's a great point and if there's
anything else anyone else wants to add
please feel free
um i do want to call out um sethara
mentioned admit weekend and those of you
on the call today are thinking about
applying right we have a september
deadline and we have a january deadline
for round one and round two both of
those rounds do have an admit weekend so
if you apply in those rounds and you are
accepted and you have the chance then to
hopefully uh by the time you are
admitted it might be in person it might
be hybrid some of it might be online um
but you will be have a chance to really
get to know students and alumni and
faculty and get a sense of what life is
like at the gsb um and that is specific
to rounds one and round two so um as
you're thinking through what rounds to
apply in
um that's just something to be aware of
um the next most upvoted question is how
did your time at stanford prepare you to
switch industries and as i look at this
slide that i'm sharing with all of you i
think
almost all of you did switch industries
and even tamar who might be in the same
technology and media switched roles so
that's just really interesting to
highlight in general that's not always
the case some people do
uh return to the same industry that they
were in
after business school but also many do
use it as a chance to pivot so i will
choose
annika and ariba maybe to start
answering this one i know heather you
already shared kind of your your
journey into entrepreneurship so
yeah
entrepreneurship particularly in the
technology space was was very
interesting to me so i i truly don't
think you can find a better program than
stanford's if that's what you want to do
um you are literally there in silicon
valley the access to understanding the
funding ecosystem for startups the
ecosystem for finding co-founders and
then all of the skill sets that you need
which are not necessarily the ones you
think you're going to need um i i i
found the curriculum was a really really
good fit for that and it was something
that i specifically asked when i was
talking to other programs and several
other programs literally their line was
you know like we're just as good as
stanford at helping you with
entrepreneurship which just was a clear
sign to me that stanford was the leader
in this category and that was very much
my experience i think very similar to
the path that heather went through of
just being able to have access to
different programs and curriculum and
just being sort of like in the soup of
of of startup world and entrepreneurship
i think also just this line about like
change organization you know change
lives change organizations change the
world sounds a little cheesy sometimes
but it's really
true you know i felt that in probably my
last week or two on campus when we had
you know different speakers and events
that were sort of putting an end cap on
our time at stanford and it was it was
real it really stood out how much of the
experience was about go forth and create
something and that doesn't necessarily
have to be entrepreneurship you can do
that in other ways but this idea of
having not only the skills but also the
like little fire inside yourself to go
and make something in this world was so
much about that experience and i i i
think stanford is just like very unique
on that front
great thanks for sharing and ariba if
you want to share you already
highlighted a little bit about just how
the gsb was integral and you um kind of
heading to apple but in terms of
switching industries how did it help
i i'll practice this with uh
i i'm an international student and i uh
for those who are on the call and and
international you know that
it's just
an added um kind of stressor because i
like to joke that i'm only ever in the
states because someone wants me to go to
their school or someone wants me to work
for their company and and i in my head
very much see the states as where i've
grown up i'm 29 i've been here since i
was 19. um but
technically you know i'm here on a visa
and so
for me coming into the gsb i think a lot
of people take time to
you know settle in and and take a few
months and get to know people uh for me
personally i support my family and
needed a visa and i was thinking about
career from i think
before i came into the gsb and had a
long to-do list and i think what was
really helpful for me in in getting
through uh that
list of stressful things to do was the
the classmates who are already at the
gsp and so
technically you don't start doing resume
drops and career events and and whatnot
until like november but i think even
just in like the summer before the gsb
in august september october i reached
out to folks in my class who were
working in product roles across like
small big medium companies that i was
interested in i was mostly looking at
product and big tech and fintech
and instead of just going directly to
potential employers or going to
alumni i just reached out to people in
my class and the class above me and that
was really helpful because it was less
stressful and i was trying to filter for
who am i talking to who i
kind of you know who kind of reminds me
of me like who would i emulate like what
company do they work at i feel like i'd
like working there because i i i like
them and i sound like them um where
should i apply and who do i talk to like
what are some friendly faces at these
places who who are not you know just the
resume drop portal and then what can i
say i have to offer like what's my
narrative what's my pitch and being able
to really refine that with classmates
was was super valuable and when it came
time to actually go to networking events
and do resume drops and do interviews um
just having all that practice was super
helpful not to say everyone should you
know start thinking about their careers
as soon as they get into business school
like take the summer off take some time
off but for the international students
on the stall um i i hear you it's
stressful you have to kind of you know
you've added stress and and i think just
leveraging the classmates that you have
even just at the gsb even you know
outside of the amazing alumni network
the folks that you're surrounded with in
the classroom and in the year above you
are a great place to start
awesome thank you for sharing um the
next question i might pose to all of you
but we'll start with heather since she
didn't answer for the last one um but
could you just share a favorite moment
you've seen of women supporting women it
could be um during your time at the gsb
or your time after also
oh gosh yeah and i'll share two quickly
one is that i have a really close group
of girlfriends from the gsb we have a
very active like group message that
probably people write in it every single
day and we zoom every other week and
we've been there for each other through
pregnancies and um job switches
promotions parents getting ill like
all kinds of life events and so i think
just like people have said having this
really small
um close set of friends that you feel
like you know everything about them and
they know everything about you
um that like support really continues on
the second is a fun note and it's going
to sound a tamer you feature so heavily
in my life um so we when we did our
first photo shoot for frankly we used a
bunch of
models from our class at gsb so tamer
was one of the models for
for frankly his first ever photo shoot
um
and the same thing when we we ran a
kickstarter last fall that was kind of
how we started the business
and
like the women's channel on our slack
blew up people were like following it
all day we got so many text messages
so i think that the women in our class
like really came together and supported
um what jane and i were trying to do
um and are still trying to do so
uh that has been really like fun and
uplifting people it was people that i
knew really well and that i loved but
also people that i didn't know as well
from school who came out and were like
this is what i'm thinking of or like i
just had a baby and now i'm thinking
about how i can breastfeed and like not
wearing a bra would be great for that so
people have been so helpful um in like
directing ideas our way and just
supporting us in every way that they can
tagging us in comments when mina harris
posts about not wearing a bra all kinds
of stuff so
awesome thanks for sharing i'm tamer do
you want to add anything to that
specifically
yeah that's definitely the first moment
um that i thought of heather because
that was so fun um like a bunch of gsb
girls got together in la and heather and
jane were so professional i must say
like there was a makeup artist like
there was a professional photographer it
was so fun um another moment that i have
is
i took this class called path to power
um
which is a little bit similar to acting
with power there's lots of classes about
power um at stanford which are fun but
this is all about i think like engaging
in power in a way that a lot of people
find uncomfortable uh but learning like
what the tactics are so that you can
understand how you can do it yourself
but also how people are engaging with
power around you in a way that you might
not have noticed and um afterward my
friend marta and i in my class created
um sort of like a group of women who
would try to do powerful things together
for the spring quarter the class happens
in the winter and we called it power
posse and it was actually so fun and we
still have like our whatsapp group to
help each other and i think it's like
okay i want to like write a medium post
like should i post it and we're all sort
of like rah-rah like you go like you
should do this and so um i think like
that's one way that i've still engaged
with women supporting women uh after the
gsb
awesome thanks um annika do you want to
add to that
yeah just both heather and tamera
reference like slack channels whatsapp
groups and i i have to just plus one
that that i think just to have
powerful amazing women like on speed
dial like in my pocket that i can text
them and know that i have someone who
can like help me prepare to negotiate an
mba like an m a deal or like help me
debug my sql query or like advise me on
how to have a difficult conversation at
work or like have a gynecologist
recommendation like all of those things
i can get from the same people and it's
just like when people talk about the
network like to have a network of also
really powerful women just is like an
extra awesome thing
yeah that's awesome so anything else to
add to that a time when you've seen
women supporting women
yeah um
a hundred percent on the the whatsapp
threads like i literally was just
texting our like women's gsb throughout
a question like earlier today so it's a
real thing
um
i just think about like a month or two
ago i was like having a having a hard
time at work and
was meeting a friend of mine just to get
a manicure in san francisco and was
talking to her and just ended up just
like it totally surprised me just like
crying while we were getting a manicure
in this nail salon and and my my friend
who was my gsb roommate um who kind of
runs her own company and who i really
kind of look up to professionally and
think is a total badass just was like
it's okay savara she was like
whenever i like cry like on a zoom call
or something like that over the last
year i've been i've just been telling
myself that it's good to have an
executive cry every now and then
and it was just like such a funny moment
of like i it had never occurred to me
that one she would even do that uh and
it was just such a it was just such a
good moment to be like oh i feel so seen
and i feel okay just like sobbing in a
nail salon right now and it's
fine so just just one moment of kind of
many like that
that's that authentic vulnerability
sharing that vulnerability it's like
actually really great
yeah yeah thank you for sharing that
arriba anything else to add um time when
women were supporting women that you
want to share
i think i think you guys covered a lot
of bases i don't have anything super
substantive to add so i'll give you that
time back great um so another upvoted
question um
so from your experiences would you say
the culture at stanford is more
collaborative or competitive i think i
know what you guys might answer but it'd
be great to um maybe share an example of
you know an example based on what your
answer is to that question so ariba why
don't we go the other way now since uh
you didn't answer another one
yeah i i
there is zero down in my mind about the
answer to this one is 100 collaborative
uh
i i
was talking to someone the other day a
mentor outside of the gsb who said that
he was struck by how i thought about
progress not as zero sum but as
something that can
that happens concurrently for many
people at once and and i was like oh
yeah i got that at the gsb like you know
everyone is just so willing to help
everyone else and it's very much kind of
an attitude of of your class um i'll
give you some examples i think just
if you're organizing an event for
instance uh i headed the tech club and i
was at the gsb with like five other
amazing classmates and
every time we bring an awesome speaker
to campus um for instance if you're
bringing the
head of uh the
senior pm for iphone to campus like ask
tech club you would reach out to product
club and also
i i don't know like design club and try
to get them to come together so that you
can get as many you know classmates as
possible to attend this awesome
discussion there is no competition for
like tech club to do an event and and
eke out another club like it would truly
not even occur to anyone to to do that
so anytime you're doing something that
might be interesting to another
classmate or another organization on
campus you loop them in um i think it's
very similar for um
just career from a career point of view
um i've never really had a classmate who
i reached out to not respond to an email
so even like when you're in mba one like
the nba dudes i think right at the
beginning feel inaccessible and just
seem to have like all of the wisdom and
you're trying to figure out like how
they got so cool and and i think i had a
lot of reservations reaching out to
people and saying hey i'm an mba one i'm
that overeager person who's already you
know thinking about interviewing will
you please talk to me about your cool
internship and
everyone always responds even if they
don't have time to meet with you
they're super busy they're not in the
country they'll you know support you by
email or slack or
webex or zoom um
yeah people are super super
collaborative i think another example is
just interview prep even if you're
applying for the same jobs because a lot
of people apply to google and apple and
the bigger companies
i prepped for interviews together i let
my classmates know hey i moved to the
next round and this is someone i talked
to who was super helpful like do you
also want to talk to them you make
introductions for folks at your old
company or at the company you interned
at it's just very much kind of in the
dna of
of the school and
whether you go to the gsb or not i i
would just advocate for all of us as as
women just seeing progress is something
that happens concurrently for all of us
and and i think sometimes like
especially in places where there aren't
enough women in leadership there can be
the attitude of oh i want to be the only
woman in power and i i didn't see any of
that at the gsb and
hopefully there will be none of that on
that on this panel of 108 people either
thank you um i don't think we have time
to get to everyone because we just have
a few minutes left but i'd love to ask
annika i'm just going in reverse order
again to chime in if you have anything
else to add about collaborative versus
competitive
i think that point on uh competing for
jobs was a good one and it made me think
of a couple of real concrete examples
something i see a lot on threads with
gsb is people who have like the job
position for their boss is open and
they'll blast it out to gsb folks or
like pick specific ones and say hey i'd
love for you to interview for this job
to like come and be my boss um or in
places where you know i've definitely
had friends who went through an
interview process didn't get the job but
then reached out to me and said i think
you might be better for this job like
here's all the information for it so
that's sort of like job sharing and
trying to help lift people up you see
all the time
awesome is there anything else that any
of you would like to add in terms of
just talking about the culture and
a time maybe that the collaborative
nature of the program was
notable to you
i i just want to do something really
fast and i think that is um the the
nature of the program is so
collaborative that you will serve
yourself the best if you come to
stanford
by telling everybody what you're
interested in or what you're passionate
about because people will bring that
back to you like tenfold if they know
what you care about they will anytime
there's an opportunity or something that
even marginally relates to it or if
they're thinking about it or talking to
someone they will point that person back
to you and that has been one of the most
powerful things that i got out of the
the stanford network is just people's um
understanding of what i cared about and
like willingness to connect me to to the
things that would make sense for that
awesome thanks for sharing i'm actually
going to flip to the next slide and i
feel like that's a really nice note to
end on because you talked about kind of
bringing yourself and knowing your
interests and being willing to share
that with people and i think you start
to hone in on that as you go through our
application process
and we ask some big questions we're
still asking the same question that all
of our panelists had to answer what
matters most to you and why
and why stanford so i encourage all of
you to continue your journey online with
us we have a lot of resources up there
um in addition to being able to track
your application you can also learn more
about courses and clubs um there are
other events offered um in the next few
weeks prior to the round one deadline so
i also encourage you to check our event
page if you're interested in attending
another panel such as this one we have
regular information sessions and we do
have some just in time webinars coming
up we call those just in time meaning
they are right before the round one
deadline so if you are stuck on
something in your application and need
advice or guidance from the admissions
team and we are here for you through
that process i encourage you to sign up
for those also i want to thank our
panelists um thank you all of you for
joining us today thank you for your time
i know many of you are calling in from
work um we just put up a poll so please
let us know your feedback on this event
and again i know this is everyone is
calling in from all over the world so i
hope that everyone has a good rest of
their day afternoon morning evening
whatever it is wherever you are thank
you so much again for your time today to
everyone
[Music]